but we'll do our best to hear from all
of you
and i have uh someone timing the three
minutes and you will hear him say
aft after you've spoken for two minutes
he'll say one minute to go
and at the end of that time he'll say
time
and we'll have to cut off your mic or
we'll ask you to complete your sentence
or one more sentence
so that we can get through as many
people as possible so
do we have uh sheriff masahos from
rockingham county
in the queue can we bring him up to be
the first speaker
mr chairman weiler i don't see him yet
but i do have the first name on the list
all right then we'll we'll hear from
kathy spinney
all right i apologize the second name is
leslie want
she's ready to speak welcome to the new
thank you very much for hearing my
testimony
um this is the first time i've gotten in
being one of the first people to testify
so thank you very much i am the vice
chair of the school board here in
manchester new hampshire
and i wanted to um just sort of make the
committee aware
of some of the challenges that the
school district faces here in manchester
as you know because of the
fewer number of students due to covet 19
we will be
losing um some
money coming to us because of the amount
of money given per
student and um that i'm just looking at
my thing here i
just i was expecting to be called so
soon um
we're looking at a retirement increase
of two and a half million dollars
we're looking at um
a reduction in fewer students of 1.2
million dollars
and um a four million dollar decrease in
funding due to uh the free
lunch applications and um so that's
a total of 7.8 million dollars lost to
the manchester school district
students over this coming year
and um so i would ask you please to take
all of that into consideration as you
as you put your budget together this
year and
anything you can do to forego um
those um cuts to us
this year would be very helpful
as you know manchester has a great
number of students with a lot of need we
have a greater percentage of
students with free reduced lunch than
any other district in the state
we also have the highest number of
uh el learners um so
we have a lot of needs here and
certainly the pandemic has
increased those needs tremendously and
this is not the year
to cut our budget so anything
you can do to help out manchester
would be in this budget would be greatly
appreciated
and i think that wraps it up for me and
i wanted to say that originally i signed
up opposed to this bill
but that was i clicked the wrong button
so that was a mistake i'm
strongly support of um anything you can
do to help out
um our education system here in
manchester
thank you for your testimony uh we've
been given word that there is more money
coming
but what we are restricted by now is
what the ways and means committee gave
us
for revenue estimates which was quite a
bit lower than what the governor had
and we have got to pass a budget that
fits within the figures that the ways
and means
committee gave us however there is hope
that more money is coming from the cares
act
we don't know when it will arrive but
hopefully that will help everything
thank you very much for your testimony
we'll next hear from leslie warren
mr chair mr chair uh sheriff manas
mizatos is available
you say the sheriff is available let's
sheriff
sheriff you need to onion yourself yup
yup okay can you hear me
okay here you go yes you can i was
trying i was trying to figure it out i
just
thank you for acknowledging me um i'm
sheriff mercedes i am the sheriff of the
rockingham county sheriff's office
i oppose this bill and i'm going to
defer it to
sheriff ricardi um on on the speaking
points about this bill
thank you good to hear from you sheriff
and just uh within the hour almost we
passed an amendment
to the section that you and i have
discussed in uh
hb2 which we hope will solve the problem
going forward as well because we've had
this problem in the past so
we've shifted some funding and we're
pretty sure that we solved the problem
thank you for coming
greg thank you thank you uh
representative wilder
for you looking into this matter and we
definitely do appreciate it thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony thank you
mr chairman
mr chairman this is representative walls
i just want to alert the clerk that i've
joined the meeting
representative wallace yes i just wanted
to alert the clerk i've joined the
meeting
wanted to know what i want to alert the
clerk
that i have joined the meeting oh thank
you very much because we missed you in
the attendance thank you for letting us
know
appreciate it all right who do we have
next on the list
well if we had uh sheriff riccardi i'd
like him to raise his hand
if not we have um next on the list is
all right let's bring bring her in
miss spinny are you available
and if you are available please raise
we have a lot of folks on here that's
quite a list to look through
okay uh the next name i'll call is james
donchett
all right james donchus the mayor
mr chairman a lot of the names the uh
uh who's ever caught making the call
outs there their hands are being raised
elizabeth o'neal is up there i see
sheriff i see sheriff riccardi
so he has raised his hand and i will
okay who do we have next uh that's the
sheriff ricardi
there he is good afternoon good
afternoon sheriff
dear chairman weiler and members of the
committee my name is dominic ricciardi
i'm the high sheriff of carroll county
i've served in law enforcement for 32
years and that includes
eight plus years as the high sheriff in
carroll county
i'm currently the president of the
sheriff's association in new hampshire
i am here to uh testify in opposition of
section one i know that you just stated
there is an amendment
amendment made but we have not seen it
yet so
i would still like to uh submit the
for the reimbursements of sheriff's
office
on behalf of the new hampshire sheriff's
association
we respectfully ask that you delete the
section in the proposed hb2
which regards the rsa-104
colon 31 roman numerals 10
and 11 in section 12 that's been added
this would drastically reduce the rate
of pay that has provided sheriff's
payless with the
judicial budget this amendment will
possibly reduce the per diem rate
from the current 108 to the rate of 2016
of 80 dollars
rates currently established in the
judicial budget are equal to those of
the
new hampshire aoc court security
officers
whom the bailiffs work alongside of in
many of the courts around the state
this agreement was made by the
collective bargaining unit
of the aoc in the judicial branch
some counties do provide a subsidy on
top of the current rate
attempt to employ adequate number of
employees
which we need to provide under rsa 104
5 number three states the bailouts shall
provide or the sheriffs
shall provide adequate security in all
state courts
except the supreme court
we are all having trouble define current
bailiffs to work this
this would be about a 26.47
rate cut if this were to pass
this proposed bill could force sheriffs
to place full-time deputies in the
courts
and provide it to provide the adequate
security needed
and will be cost to the taxpayers in the
and also possibly lose police services
around the towns that have no police in
these counties
we respectfully ask that this section
and amendments be removed from hb2
as we see it as a cost shift to the
counties and
thank you for consideration
thank you sheriff um we did pass an
amendment
about an hour ago that will be
publicized soon and you will get a look
at it when it's
available on the lba website uh an
amendment to
section one of hb2 and we believe it has
solved the problem
and as you point out it's been a
long-standing problem
going forward we think we fixed it so
take a look at that we've
changed where the fund sources were and
things like that so
we think we fixed everything we hope we
can go back to uh
camera arrangements again
but we've got to convince the court of
that that should save a lot of
transportation money that you have to
spend so
take a look at it we think we fixed it
thank you for coming before us
what do we have here we have the nashua
mayor
um
thank you mr chair um thank you for
hearing me
um i'm here to testify i guess in
opposition of the bill
because of the 73 million dollar
gap in education funding between the
last last fiscal year and the fiscal
year
coming up this is the worst time to hit
school districts across the state with
this
funding gap because the
challenges caused by the pandemic are
really unprecedented
a lot of kids who have tried to try to
learn remotely and
all the problems associated with that
also it really
the the loss in education aid reflects
some
artificial reductions in uh
the so-called the free and reduced lunch
kids and
in attendance uh the those are the two
main drivers of the reduction in the
education costs
two minutes the free and reduced lunch
reduction has been caused by the fact
that
the department of agriculture federal
made all free lunches all lunches free
so there's no real incentive anymore for
there's certainly much less incentive
for families to qualify for free and
reduced lunch
we know that low-income families
moderate income families have been hit
very hard by the pandemic
we expect we think that there are more
free and reduced lunch qualifiers
but that people just haven't had to
haven't filled out the paperwork so
that's an artificial
reduction also the reduction in
enrollments is also artificial
i'm just telling you nashville's
experience because i think it's typical
almost all the reduction comes from the
pre-k
and kindergarten levels where when the
schools were remote
uh they're moving and they've moved into
hybrid now but when they were
there was no particular you know it was
easy for a parent to say look i'm not
going to send my kid to a remote
kindergarten or remote pre-k
so that caused an artificial reduction
there
this comes at the same time when state
retirement costs have been
elevated for all cities and towns very
dramatically
so this this hit on the tax the property
taxpayers is one
that i don't believe can be afforded and
i'm hoping
you mr chairman members of the committee
will at least equalize the education
aid for the coming year with the
coming fiscal year with the current
fiscal year until we work out these
pandemic related problems thank you for
hearing me
thank you we're we're aware of that
problem we've heard about it several
times
um this is this is a
only on uh march 16th this budget won't
be completed until sometime in june
there is some possibility of more funds
coming in in the cares act
and some of them will be dead dedicated
to education
in the interim we don't have that much
money that for
what's been asked but we're hoping that
there'll be some in that and also
the if in fact the revenue picture
improves which some people think
uh march and april being big months for
revenue
then we will have more figures to work
with but we're stuck with what
the figures we got in february so but
i'm looking forward to rosie days and
hopefully we're all out well hopefully
hopefully they will come
thank you mr chair all right thank you
who do we have next the next name i see
on the list promoting is ken
norton okay
thank you chairman weiler and members of
the committee my name is kenneth norton
and i'm the executive director of naming
new hampshire the national alliance on
mental illness
our mission is to improve the lives of
all people impacted by mental illness
and or suicide
during governor sununu budget address he
once again stated that new hampshire is
in a mental health crisis
and i'm here to ask you to fully fund
mental health services as proposed in
the governor's budget
the crisis has been exacerbated by the
pandemic with significant increases in
stress anxiety
and depression across all ages though
particularly impacting children and
youth
the most visible symptom of the board is
the boarding of individuals in a mental
health crisis in emergency departments
while waiting for an inpatient bed
this is a practice nami new hampshire
has long described as wrong
medically legally ethically morally and
economically during the past month we've
exceeded previous highs
of the numbers of people being boarded
with 51 children being boarded on
february 14th
and a combined high of 89 children and
adults
on february 17th emergency department
boarding is the tip of the proverbial
iceberg relative to costly access to
mental health care
there are long waits for outpatient
treatment as well workforce shortages
pose an ongoing challenge
to addressing this crisis and fully
funding the state's loan repayment
program
is critical to addressing mental health
and other health related fields
suicide continues to be a significant
public health issue in our state as well
with suicide being the second leading
cause of death after
accidental injury in new hampshire for
those ages 10 through 34.
we anticipate that the mental health
impacts of the pandemic will continue
for some time to come
and will impact children parents older
adults and across many sectors of our
workforce
we're already seeing evidence of this we
must continue the work begun during the
2019 legislative session of implementing
the key recommendations of the
2019 10-year mental health plan this
includes continuing
to focus on developing a continuum of
community-based services for mental
health crisis response
step up and step down services inpatient
and outpatient capacity
supported housing peer support suicide
prevention and substance use disorder
services
we must also move ahead with building a
new forensic hospital in order to end
the practice of people with mental
health conditions
who have not been charged with crimes
being transferred to the department of
corrections and the secure
psychiatric unit it's imperative that we
continue to prioritize mental health
funding
in order to address the mental health
crisis we're in fully funding
community-based
services and supports as proposed will
reduce
costs and human impact on child
protective services juvenile
justice education courts and corrections
in other key areas
lastly as a member of the governor's law
enforcement accountability community and
transparency commission
i offer my strong support for fully
funding police standards and training
as included in the budget thank you all
to the finance committee members for
your hard work and your service to our
state
uh thank you for your testimony we have
discussed some of these problems with
the hhs
to find that they're having hiring
problems and
as well as space problems we've we've
had this these
things ongoing as you know for quite a
while and we're hoping that we can fix
it but it's going to be
a little bit longer term than any of us
would like but we're hoping for better
things in future future
thank you for pointing that out thank
you
all right who do we have next mr speaker
this is representative walls
i just got a call on a landline from
somebody saying miss finney's been
called
but apparently they couldn't unmute her
or something and that she's still there
with her hand up and they asked that i
relay that to you
um so i'm just relaying what came in on
a landline it's a miss finney
does she uh have her hand up that's what
they told me
yes star nine do you know if she is
not sure if she is fired tablet
unidentified
nancy you know as much as i do i'm just
relaying what came in on the call i'm
sorry i don't have that
um um do we have the name representative
walls
yes it was a finney uh maybe candy
yeah if she's um the only unidentified
hand uprights i see right now is fire
tablet
i can promote that that individual i
something does she do is it is a star
six to raise your hand when you're
on a phone and star sticks to unmute
this is fire tablet how do you get
attention
star six on mutes but how do you get
attention uh
raid your hands star nine that was a
wreath
[Applause]
this is fire tablet can you please
identify yourself hello
can you hear me yes i can hear you
please identify yourself
this is kathy spinney from pelham new
hampshire very good i apologize ma'am
please go ahead that's okay this is new
spell your last name s-p-i-n-n-e-y
thank you i'm calling to
ask the committee to i'm in favor of hb1
particularly all the line items under
the bureau of developmental services
i'm asking you to support fully funding
those and
if if you're feeling you know generous
increasing those amounts i am the parent
of a 39 year old adult young woman with
developmental disability disabilities
significant disabilities she requires
full care
my angle on this is i'm 63 years old now
she's getting very heavy to carry around
and i don't anticipate that my physical
ability is going to improve
so more and more and more the demands of
her
care needs to fall to staff she's got
wonderful staff
but they're getting older too and i'm
sure you're all aware of the workforce
shortage we have
because we just can't pay people enough
or we haven't been paying people enough
to become just
direct support professionals and do this
very challenging work
so one of the things that i worry about
as i'm getting older is what in the name
of heaven is going to happen to my
daughter
when i'm not here anymore to provide the
many hours
that i still do provide in addition to
working full-time
we really need to fund these services
and consider giving direct support
professionals enough of a living wage to
attract people to the field
that's one of the biggest problems um
that we have
implementing services our loved ones are
eligible for
so again i'm asking you to fully fund
the line items
under developmental services and
increase them if
hhs has told us one of the biggest
problems is finding space
and finding people but we'll be working
on that continuously but thank you for
pointing it out
who do we have next chair there are a
number of people with their hands
up that i would like to ask to please
lower their hand
unless they've been called already
because that's making it very difficult
to locate folks that are on the list
so please lower your handle if you've
been called we have called the name of
elizabeth o'neill
elizabeth if you're there please raise
your hand
if not jillian doucet
billian if you're there please raise
your hand
if you're on the phone please raise your
hand with star9
if not we have nancy kelleher
nancy kelleher if not
we have jackie cowell
believe i saw her name as available
there she is
thank you jackie it will promote you to
panelists
one moment there she is
jackie please mute there you go thank
you
good afternoon everyone thank you uh
hi so um i'm jackie cowell i'm from
early learning new hampshire
and um i'll be really brief and uh
i'm talking about um page 950
of the budget around child care so um
it is under health and human services it
is uh
the 2 9 child development program to be
specific
and it is class 536 employment related
child care so i'm asking um
for you to please consider putting
enough money
in this line item to be sure that we
don't start a wait list
for folks who are lower income and need
this little bit of state assistance to
afford
child care to keep working this is the
very specifically for folks who are
income eligible right now they're
working hard
and they need this child care the
governor's budget does propose a cut
of up to 20 percent here and the
department has
explained it's because there has been
um uh expenditures haven't kept
pace but um we really
believe with the with the pandemic with
all sorts of ways that you can support
families who qualify for child care
there could be very many more that are
qualifying we ask that you
have some kind of mechanism in place to
make sure we don't start a wait list
back in 2008 2009 during the last
recession we did start a wait list in
new hampshire and
we found that many families were
had to turn down jobs they were offered
or leave a job they were currently
in because they just couldn't find a
child care that they afforded without
this assistance
so a wait list really hurts those
families who are
working hard to get ahead we hope you
pay um special attention to 536
and the other quick thing that i would
mention
is that the right below 536 is
564 protecting and preventing
preventative child care this helps those
families that are
um children who have been victims of
abuse or neglect
or are at risk to make sure they have
stable reliable child care
and the department has asked for another
2 million per year there and we
support that as well so thank you very
much i appreciate it
thank you for your testimony and who do
we have next
we have christina darling followed by
amy brooks amy if you could please raise
your hand
i know where to find you and ms darling
if you could unmute yourself
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee
my name is christina darling and i live
in nashua new hampshire with my two boys
caden and brennan both of whom receive
the new hampshire child care scholarship
allow me to start by saying that when i
was a kid it was never my intention or
desire to need to receive state
assistance to survive
however when i found myself suddenly a
single mom
with no local family support and two
small boys who depended on me for
absolutely everything
survival was the only thing that
mattered survival meant paying the bills
which means i needed to work in order to
work i needed child care
to get child care i needed money it's a
terrifying loop that i wouldn't wish on
anyone without the new hampshire child
care scholarship i'd still be stuck in
that loop
the scholarship allowed me to find
full-time employment and keep my
apartment
while also ensuring my children were
safe and cared for while i was gone
during the day
you see i have big dreams for my family
someday i hope to buy a house and take
my kids on a vacation to experience a
different culture and pay for them to go
to college
but even with my full-time job where i
provide essential services and resources
to families in affordable housing
in a perfect month where no bills go
over and my food cost stays down
i can walk away with 75 dollars a month
to put in savings
believe it or not that's more than i
ever have before
if i didn't have access to the child
care scholarship i'd be back to juggling
my bills and trying to explain to my
kids why we don't have power when all of
our neighbors do
i want to take a moment just to tell you
about my sister she's an essential
worker who had to leave her job as a
nursing
assistant during a time when we need
health care workers
the cost of child care compared to the
income she made
working with our most vulnerable was
just too much and due to issues with the
new hampshire child care scholarship one
minute
it was more cost effective for her to
leave her job and apply for other state
assistants that's emergency rental
assistance utility assistance
medicaid for her and her kids cash
assistance and food stamps
i've often wondered what costs more
child care scholarship
or paying for the family of fives
welfare
i pride myself in setting the best
possible example i can for my boys i
really show them what a strong
independent woman looks like
and what it means to step up and take
care of your family
not asking for handouts i proudly earn
everything i work for everything i earn
i'm speaking out today in opposition of
hb1
and i would ask that you put yourselves
in the minds and shoes of your essential
workers who rely on child care
scholarships
so that moms like me and my sister can
build a savings reach our financial
goals
and pull our families up and out of
poverty permanently
thank you all for your time and for
allowing me to be here and share my
testimony with you
thank you for your testimony we're
working on all those areas
okay next mr chair we have amy brooks
followed by
very good miss brooks getting on the
list
yourself miss brooks
thank you for this opportunity my name
is amy brooks i was the owner and
director of a nationally accredited
center in colebrook new hampshire
for 20 years i've experienced the impact
of the employment related child care
scholarship
and in coast especially it's not
uncommon to consistently have 50 percent
of our children
qualifying for child care scholarship
i remember a time when when employment
related child care
scholarship was underfunded and that had
created
a waiting list i recall on many
occasions a mom
being ready to re-enter the workforce
after being home with their young
children only to find
that they were wait listed and to
receive child care assistance
they had to defer the job and inform
their potential employer who was eager
to hire
that they would not be rejoining the
workforce after all
currently in co-op specifically in
colebrook we're experiencing an increase
in manufacturing
and a workforce shortage it is critical
that families
continue to be able to access high
quality child care
and without that access the workforce
will continue to be stifled
and this economic growth opportunity
will be seriously interrupted
access to child care is critical in
rebuilding new hampshire's economy
and up here in coast we have
opportunities
now to rebuild but these opportunities
can only be realized when parents have
access to child care
a fully funded employment related
assistance budget is
key to this rebuild thank you
next we have jane marquis
i don't have any response we have
i'm not getting response um
we have uh jim deramus
mr speaker this is representative walls
again
i just got a text from representative
amanda tolle
saying that she was called to testify
that she couldn't unmute quickly enough
and that she's in the waiting room and
asking that you call her again
what was the name again representative
wallace representative amanda tolle
okay i've not called that name but we
can put her on the list
i don't know i don't know if she was on
the list we're going to go through the
list before we go to people that are
raising their hands newly well she's
suggesting that
uh she was she says they called on me
but i could not on
on mute in time oh they did call on her
that's what she's just texted me we
don't have that name
um we had an elizabeth o'neal
and nancy kelleher are the only other
names that were called
she's not but i'll look for her but
she is on this list uh she is
not um amanda told from keen is not due
to testify for several spots
and we just have a list that we are
going by that was generated in order of
when folks registered
so if someone needs to be moved up for
some reason
the chair needs to decide that but we
are going in order
i understand that i just wanted to alert
you to this text
we have a 10 i've been asking the folks
when i call their name to raise their
hand
but folks are raising their hand for
other reasons so
we are just going in order of the list
that was generated
at this time until the chair directs us
otherwise
mr deramus your name was called and you
are available to speak
good thank you very much thank you mr
chairman and members of the
finance committee my name is jim doremus
and i'm the ceo of the concord family
ymca
i'm here today on behalf of the ymca
alliance of new hampshire
which is comprised of the nine ymcas in
our state
collectively the ymca is the largest
provider of child care and summer camp
in the granite state
we serve more than fifteen thousand kids
in camp three thousand
kids in before and after school programs
and more than 1 000 young children in
our early education programs each year
approximately 20 percent of the children
we serve participate in the subsidy
program
the ymca alliance of new hampshire
strongly opposes the cut to the child
care scholarship
program the child care subsidy
scholarship program
is critical support for thousands of new
hampshire children to access safe and
quality care
now more than ever due to the continued
impacts of the kovid 19 pandemic
we know families need this program
please keep enough funding in the
employment related child care line in
the budget so that we don't have to
start a waitlist for this important
service
on behalf of the state's nine ymcas we
thank the opportunity to be part of this
conversation um
thank you again thank you for your
testimony
next we have joseph leskov
okay uh i've promoted you
please unmute yourself sir hello can you
hear me
yes sir all right thank you um
my name is joseph laskas i am
representing the american civil
liberties union of new hampshire
um on this and we are in opposition
to hb one on the original
proposal to cut both the education
department
and the transitional housing from the
department of corrections
um the fact that i have a criminal
background is a
known fact but not something i generally
like to talk about
or enjoy doing i do though voluntarily
share this information in hopes that the
experiences i've been through would help
new hampshire create a
better system for rehabilitating and
creating successful opportunities for
formerly incarcerated individuals
i paroled from the prison system in 2019
and over the 13 years i was incarcerated
i met and saw many people parole from
the prison system
i don't personally know every individual
who's paroled from the prison system but
everyone i personally know that has been
rehabilitated has participated
in the educational opportunities
provided at the dlc
the education department provides an
environment where people learn a
rehabilitative mode of thinking
and it's a place where uh hope is
instilled in others to see
opportunities available through
education and that is so important
because we live in a society where the
value of education is underscored by the
fact that
this information is required on every
job application i can think of
so i don't understand how this
legislator could consider removing one
of the most critical tools used to
helping
re-entering society members succeed in
the new hampshire community
and this leads to the second component
of re-entry which is transitional
housing
eliminating transitional housing from
the budget closes the doors both
literally and figuratively on those
residents who are
in those housing units the transitional
housing system
is a system that is built to help people
continue their rehabilitative path back
into the community
as they experience the shock of going
from one world to the next
as well as preparing them for the
challenges that they're going to
go through when they parole so i
respectfully ask that this
committee places both the education
department
and the transitional housing back into
the budget and approves it
here in new hampshire thank you i have
good news for you
about 11 30 we restored the education
for the corrections department
however long-term transitional housing
which we've been asked for in many
different
is a long-term effect and it's very
difficult to either build it or locate
it but we'll keep working on it thank
you
mr chair next up i have carolyn virtue
but i do not see her in the
queue carolyn if you're there could you
please raise your hand
and after carolyn is steve ahnen and i
i have paula minihan from the hospital
association and i believe
she may be in for mr anand so i will
paula can you unmute yourself there you
go thank you
yes good afternoon and i am filling in
for stevon and unfortunately he had a
death in the family um
for the record paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations
for the new hampshire hospital
association thank you for this
opportunity
new hampshire hospitals and the
healthcare heroes who work in them are
driven by the mission to provide health
high quality health care and improve the
health and well-being of the communities
they serve
new hampshire hospitals remain committed
to caring for their communities and
ensuring access to quality compassionate
care
this is true every day and that resolve
has certainly been
demonstrated throughout the past year
but hospitals have been challenged over
the past year as we have responded to
the kobit 19
pandemic when cobit 19 arrived in new
hampshire hospitals became the front
lines of defense against the highly
contagious
and dangerous disease from securing
scarce
personal protective equipment standing
up additional capacity to treat coven 19
patients canceling non-urgent elective
procedures
standing up testing capacity around the
state and
our hospitals have responded with great
compassion
and care to ensure that their patients
were able to get the care that they
needed
the pandemic has challenged us all and
working together we believe we can
emerge from this crisis
but it will take great care to ensure
that the new hampshire
does have does so in ensuring that we
are
able to serve the citizens across the
state we are
also very focused on the medicaid
program and it is absolutely
essential that we have a robust and
effective medicaid program that helps to
ensure recipients
are getting the right care at the right
time in the right place
and we are appreciative that the house
bill one
put forth by governor sununu includes
the medicaid
enhancement tax and medicaid
disproportionate share
program settlement agreement provisions
that were
negotiated years ago and we appreciate
that we are also very appreciative of
this
rate increase that were included in the
last budget and maintained in the state
in the budget before the house the a
budget is designed to address
key priorities in the state and there
are many that we navigate
through the coveted 19 pandemic however
there is no more
urgent and pressing priority than the
addressing the behavioral health crisis
facing new hampshire
as we have said before any plan that is
focused on solving the totality of the
behavioral
health crisis must be a clear focus on
addressing the challenge of patients
waiting in the emergency rooms today
tomorrow next week and next year it
needs to be part of a comprehensive
solution
in addition to increasing inpatient
capacity to solve the emergency
room boarding crisis provide increases
to community-based
services across the continuum of care in
outpatient
mobile crisis crisis stabilization and
many others
so that patients can access care and
treatment before
because there's your three minutes thank
you
thank you for your testimony thank you
next we have laura pelletier followed by
jemima chapman and lynn charlotte
and i would ask those individuals to
please raise their hands so we can find
them
and anyone else to please lower your
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee
i am laura pelletier i live in
moultonborough and
i am director at interlakes daycare
center and nursery school in meredith
i am here to talk to you about child
care interlakes daycare center is
celebrating its 50th anniversary this
year
during the last year we never closed we
stayed open for the families of
essential workers
so that they could continue working
historically around 40 percent of
our children that we care for are from
low income families who qualify for the
child care scholarship
many people wouldn't expect that to be
true of a town
like meredith but that need is
absolutely there
in a tourist town many of the people who
live here
year round work in retail and service
jobs
we're now getting more and more families
calling who
aren't uh sorry who are going back to
work and who qualify for the child care
scholarship
we believe the need for those families
to be able
to access affordable childcare is going
to be
it was before if not a greater need if
there ends up being a waitlist for
scholarships
these parents can't work uh when this
happened a few
years back we know that it means that
they needed to qualify for higher levels
of state assistance
through the years i personally have seen
the scholarship program help families
get ahead
these families are able to afford
childcare to grow in their job and
contribute to the economy
i would like to tell you about one of
our former parents
she was a single mom she had a toddler
and she had told us that she wanted to
own her own business someday that she
had known from the time she was a
teenager what she wanted to do in life
and that's what she was working toward
she qualified for the scholarship
program and her son attended our program
while she worked
we got to see her start her business and
then grow it year after year
and she is now a successful
businesswoman who
not only is incredibly successful in her
field but
also now gives back to the community she
um has taught classes and she regularly
donates
to local charities using her business
profits
if she hadn't been able to access this
scholarship i don't think that she would
be where she is today
and there are stories like this that
child care providers all across the
state
could share um in closing i would ask
that you put enough funding in the
employment related child care line to
make sure that
every eligible parent who is working or
looking for work
can use it to get ahead thank you very
much for listening
thank you for your testimony it's good
to hear that the program is working
next up we have jemima chapman
go ahead miss miss chapman you're you're
live
hi i'm jemima chapman um good afternoon
mr
chairman and members of the committee
i'm an executive director
at a nationally accredited child care
center in kingston new hampshire
and i'm here just to ask you to please
keep enough funding
in the new hampshire child care budget
for scholarships because families
this gives them that initial boost to
get back to work
and i seen so many families use this be
able to get back to work
start providing for their family and
then later be
able to self-sufficiently pay their
child care
and one of my examples is
some an employee that is here at the
kingston children's center
and she had children using the child
care scholarship
and without her here and without others
like her here
we would be short-staffed um
and she has been able to go back to
school since having her children
attending here and using that child care
scholarship and she
now is able to self-sufficiently pay her
childcare
but it was just a tremendous boost for
her
so i thank you for listening and
please keep that money available for
these families that need it
next we have i apologize we have lynn
charlotte followed by
erica bro erica if you could raise your
hand next so we can find you
great wonderful thank you very much mr
chairman and members of the committee
for this opportunity my name is lynn
chalet and i'm the executive director at
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence
i'm here today in support of house bill
1 and the allocation for domestic
violence and sexual assault services
this allocation would ensure that the
state budget adequately funds the
life-saving services that are provided
by our 13 crisis centers
to address sexual assault and domestic
violence across our state
over the last two years new hampshire's
crisis center served nearly thirty
thousand individual victims including
providing shelter to just over one
thousand adults and children in our 12
emergency domestic violence shelters
for a total of over 86 000 bed nights
yet at the same time 1 672 adults and
740 children had to seek shelter
elsewhere because we just didn't have
the capacity in our programs
as a state we have worked tirelessly to
respond to the opioid crisis
the lack of mental health services which
you've heard about today
to improve child protection and to
address the shortages we are
experiencing in adequate housing
however we must continue to recognize
that many individuals are in need of
all of these services as a direct result
of family violence domestic abuse and
sexual assault
when we as a state begin to respond
earlier and more comprehensively
to victimization and trauma we will
reduce the impact and the cost of these
crimes in our communities
the essential role that crisis centers
play in our communities to respond to
trauma has become increasingly apparent
over the last year as we have witnessed
the devastating impact
that the covet 19 pandemic has had in
the granite state
imagine the terror of being asked to
shelter at home with the person who is
battering or raping you
every single day despite the added
barriers that made it really challenging
for victims to reach out to advocates
crisis centers received nearly 100 000
emergency calls
through their crisis 2020 representing
almost a 40 increase in calls from 2019.
so what i hope this committee will
consider is that when victims don't
receive support
especially as children the long-term
effects of trauma manifest in a variety
of ways
including chronic physical and mental
health issues
depression suicide substance abuse
disorders
and difficulty maintaining employment
when we as a state work to reduce
domestic and sexual violence we will
reduce
these negative impacts on new
hampshire's communities
our families our businesses our health
care system
and our economy thank you for your
consideration of this proposed budget
next we have erica breaux followed by
cheryl bailey and aaron bouvier and if
miss bailey and miss bouvier could raise
their hands
so we can promote you next i appreciate
it thank you
bro you're live hello my name is erica
i was raised in laconia and currently
live in guilford
i'm a site director for a child care
center in belmont
new hampshire is a wonderful place to
live work and raise a family
yet in life there are struggles that a
lot of people face
every day now more than ever
i believe it is important to receive a
hand up not a handout which is what
child care assistance
does for families i'm a single mom of
two boys
i've worked for lakes region child care
from 2006 to 2019
when we merged with the boys and girls
club of central new hampshire
i have been the site director for
belmont early learning center
since 2010 i'm here today to share my
experiences of how state assistance has
impacted my life as a single mom and
also
as a child care administrator i have
experienced the impact and have seen how
families are impacted by this
on a daily basis my employment over the
years has provided me with a stable
income
health insurance it gave my children the
opportunity for early learning
and a connection with a deep and wide
support system
who many never even thought existed
still the only way i was able to afford
and keep my employment
was to continue receiving child care
assistance having the ability to access
assistance over the years helped me
to be able to not only keep my job but
move up
in my career it played a huge part in
where i am today
as a parent i value the experiences the
early education field has
offered my children i enjoy the daily
responsibilities that come with my
profession
and most importantly i take pride in
contributing
to them to be a contributing member of
our society
as a child care administrator i know the
impact having child care assistance has
on our families and
accessing high quality programs as an
organization we have over a hundred
members that are currently receiving
assistance
pre-covered it was 175 members
it is the assistance for families that
makes it so they can continue
employment and send their children to a
high quality program
we all know that in a stable nurturing
environment
surrounded by attentive caregivers
children are better able to acquire the
social
cognitive language and life skills that
are so vital for future success
such children are far more likely to
grow into healthy
happy and responsible adults they're
more likely to succeed in school
and on the job and raise healthy
families of their own
in other words if we want to be
surrounded by great neighbors
in a great community twenty years from
now we need to lay the foundation for
them today
which requires providing families the
supports they need to continue being
employed
and having a safe place for their
children to go time
mr chair we had called the names of
cheryl bailey
and aaron bouvier but i do not see their
hands raised
so the next person on the list is
elizabeth
margolin followed by representative
timothy horrigan and i would ask mr
horrigan
to raise his hand so we can find him and
an analyst good afternoon thank you um
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is alyssa margolin
i serve as director of housing action
new hampshire we're a statewide
coalition of 80 organizations
united around affordable housing policy
and ending
homelessness in new hampshire as uh you
know
new hampshire is experiencing a true
shortage in housing
we have a supply side problem in our
state
particularly in the rental market this
is causing
a financial hardship among many
of new hampshire families who are paying
more than 50
of their monthly income towards their
rent
in fact over half of our renter
population
which makes up about a third of all
residents of new hampshire
are paying too much when you pay too
much for your rent it means you don't
have money
to put in the rest of your local economy
in an otherwise strong economy before
the pandemic
housing was a weak spot for our state
continues to challenge us i'd like to
bring to the attention of this committee
three aspects in the budget
uh uh to consider as you consider hb1
and hb2
and as the when the budget comes back to
you from the senate and you have a
chance
to consider appropriations in the
committee of conference
first i ask that you look at the
affordable housing fund this is new
hampshire's state housing trust fund
where public dollars leverage private
capital
to build more affordable housing second
ask you to consider funding for
homeless shelter operations it cost
about 47 dollars per person per
night to shelter someone in new
hampshire the state currently reimburses
that service at eight dollars and eighty
cents
uh so increased money for homeless
shelter operations
can provide at least some sustainability
and help
those shelters address the increase in
homelessness and the rise in encampments
in our state
and finally i would just ask that you uh
consider
um to keep the funding for the housing
appeals board that the governor has
included in his budget and with that
i'll conclude my testimony thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony next we
have representative
timothy horrigan followed by william
maddox and
elliott berry if you could please raise
your hands
representative oregon you want to mute
yourself
do that okay i've got the buttons first
i know you didn't even see me
not to not that you would have been
missing much if you couldn't so i'm
president timothy horrigan i represent
stratfor county district six the towns
of durham and madbury
and of course the durham is very uh
durham is significant that's the home of
unh
and first i'm gonna say i'm not sure if
i'm
going to before against the version of
hp 1 and 2 which will come to the floor
of the house it's on april 7th
i'm sure it's going to be different than
what the governor do so that's what i'm
working off of
i'm certainly opposed to that and um
and also of course he introduced a few
days late on march 2nd i'm not sure if
the significance of this but we are
behind schedule so
the u.s first thing about where durham
comes in
usnhcc nh merger i know there's lots of
advantages different that are supposedly
to lead to
those good things are already being done
um even without the merger
i think the experience the past shows
that the merger is pointless and
unnecessary um
also probably more importantly there's a
small business development center
the governor proposed smashing its
budget um that's
probably the most productive money we
spent um the tax cut rates
pointless you're going to have no
stimulus effect that's a fantasy that
there's going to be
credible economic growth the tax cut
it's going to make no difference
to anybody's spending or investment
decisions none because they're just
small tax cuts and reducing revenues
not necessarily a good thing if it does
reduce spending it's actually not bad
for the economy and actually especially
not when we do the things we're always
making tough choices like
you hear a lot about helping the
vulnerable um that's actually good for
the economy helping you vulnerable um
so finally on a happier note the
governor proposed it definitely
enhancing the legislative branch's
budget i
i think that's long overdue we need a
lot more resources to our
job more staff more infrastructure more
everything i know that's
not fastable but we need to spend more
than we've been spending and
running the legislative branch from the
cheap minimally staffed using automotive
processing technology it didn't work
pretty pandemic
i thought we were pretty outmoded even
when um i got here that was 12 years ago
we made no changes
one minute okay i thought zero minutes
okay so running the legislative ranch
minimally
staffed using outlet of processing
technology it didn't work for the
pandemic um
it's not working during the pandemic
although we we've made some good changes
and you know we're
we're still here we're still running and
it won't work uh
post pandemic so that's basically why
basically i'm playing to vote against
the budget i you recognize you're going
to go to the senate there's also
you may have to hold it over the summer
and so but uh right now hb1
hb2 as i understand that i'm i'm voting
against it so
that's basically what i had to say
thanks
thank you for your testimony
representative horgan again i'm going to
send you some
email using some written testimony in a
mr chair next we have phil maddox
followed by elliott berry and chris dean
stoddard if you could both raise your
hand and if you are on a phone call
good afternoon can you hear me yes yes
okay mr chairman and committee members
my name is bill maddox i'm a small
business owner from amherst and i'm
testifying today
against hv1 and hp2
committee is well aware of the massive
toll was shut down required to protect
lives taken
on families in the granite state
even before the pandemic 33 of people in
new hampshire were poor or low income
total of 439 000 residents
greater than 47 percent of new hampshire
renters are paying more than 30 percent
of their income for housing
nearly half of new hampshire adults
reported a loss of household
employment between march and july of
last year
and significant portions of households
expected future employment income losses
or reported difficulty paying for usual
expenses
consistently since april 2020 about one
in every twenty households in new
hampshire indicated
there was either sometimes or not enough
or
often not enough food to eat in the last
several days
new hampshire has a seventh highest per
capita number of millionaires
in the country and according to forbes
magazine people in the highest income
levels have seen their wealth increase
by 1.3 trillion since
march 2020 an increase of 44 percent
the governor's budget proposes those
least impacted by the pandemic
of getting a tax break these are the two
point four percent of new hampshire
taxpayers
will report at least two hundred
thousand dollars in taxable interest
dividend and distribution income
i can assure you i am not one of them
the budget proposes reducing the rate of
and eventually eliminating the interest
in dividends tax over five years
and again giving a handout to the
state's wealthiest households
this tax revenue source generated 125.7
million for the general fund
in state fiscal year 2020 or 8.2 percent
of all general fund revenue collected
that year a repeal of the tax would lead
to significant revenue losses
relevant relative to current policy
our economy is recovery from the
pandemic and budget restructure
reductions have been proposed the
department of safety department of
transportation department of education
under fighting of child care services
we've heard from other speakers
by millions which could dramatically
increase the wait list
and discontinuation of over 40 million
dollars in municipal aid funding
in the 2020 budget which could lead to
substantial property tax
increases the priorities of this budget
are misguided and should be amended by
the legislature
at a time when our nation and our state
are moving towards recovery
from the greatest economic downturn
since the great depression when
thousands of our neighbors are in the
midst of economic peril
giving the wealthiest among us a tax
break does not pass the moral test
next we have christine stoddard
because i do not see mr barry's hand
we've skipped him
followed by laura gifford and doug
mcnutt and if those two individuals
could raise their hand
so we can find them thank you
yeah good afternoon
mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is christine stoddard
and i'm the director of
public policy at bi-state primary care
association
thank you for allowing us to speak to to
the state budget
we did sign in as neutral and i will
submit written testimony but i wanted to
draw your attention to two issues that
were raised last week in division three
one of them was the state loan repayment
program and the second issue that i
wanted to discuss with you today is the
family planning program
bi-state is a non-profit organization
that's located in beau
and we advocate for access to primary
and preventive care
for all new hampshire residents with a
special emphasis on the medically
underserved
we also represent new hampshire's 14
community health centers which are
located in medically underserved areas
and those health centers provide
integrated substance use disorder
treatment behavioral health
primary care and oral health services
to a hundred and twenty thousand
patients one of five who
are enrolled in the medicaid program
last week in division three
dhhs testified that there is a program
within house bill 2
that is intended to replace the state
loan repayment program
and we would ask that instead of
replacing slurp as it's affectionately
known
that these programs operate
simultaneously
they are designed to meet very different
needs and
serve very different purposes and it's
my understanding that they were speaking
to the
workforce development debt relief
program that begins on page 70.
we would ask that the state loan
repayment program continue
as it is and as it was funded in the
2019 budget which was at six and a half
million dollars
um as you know this program provides
partial payment towards educational
loans of qualified health care
professionals
in exchange for working in medically
underserved areas
so we would ask that that program
continue we also
respectfully request that an additional
1.2 million dollars be added to the
family planning program
because as many of you know there is a
change at the federal level that affects
who can participate in this program
and participate in the federal funding
for that program
and we would like that the general funds
be added so that there are no gaps in
services in the family planning program
thank you for your time and i am happy
to answer any questions if you have them
thank you for your testimony we're not
equipped to get into a debate and answer
questions but we appreciate your offer
thank you very much thank you take care
next up we have laura gifford
followed by doug mcnutt and new futures
if new future could raise their hand
hello can you hear me yes yes
hi my name is laura gifford and i
am a school nurse i am a member
a resident of jaffrey new hampshire and
i'm writing
to urge you to support
the children's behavioral health
services
i'm a registered nurse for 30 years
and currently work as a practicing
school nurse
during my 11 years at wilton lyme
borough cooperative
school district i've observed
an increase in the children's mental
health
problems since the beginning of covid
continuous exposure to toxic stress
can be detrimental to a child's
overall overall well-being
untreated mental health illnesses in
early childhood
can lead to negative emotional
in chronic health diseases such as
diabetes hypertension depression
and anxiety beyond a child's physical
and mental health a lack of child
children's behavioral health services
can lead to delinquency high risk
behavior
and even a child's likelihood to
of educational attainment
the cdc has produced a short video clip
that i have
explains why we should be champions of
children
and their support groups and i've listed
on my letter that i sent in
i feel like supporting the efforts to
help children
in the state of new hampshire will
benefit
all of the citizens to becoming all that
they can be
investing in our children's behavior and
mental well-being today
thank you and i i do uh appreciate your
time
to listen to my testimony
i thank you for your testimony thank you
for coming
and if not if you could have mute
uh hi members of the committee my name
is doug mcnutt can you hear me yes
okay great um so i am the associate
state director for advocacy for aarp new
hampshire and we represent over
215 000 members statewide
and one of the things that is always
clear about our members although they
don't agree on everything
over 90 percent of them believe that
they want to stay at home as long as
they can
in their communities as they age and my
focus today is really going to be on one
issue and that is the choices for
independence waiver
which is the program that is designed
for those who are eligible to be in a
nursing home
but uh can be taken care of at home
and the reason it's important is it
allows people to stay at home
it is less expensive and as we've seen
in this pandemic it is safer for people
to stay at home
one of the things that i would point out
is there's a report that
just has been released by the department
of health and human services
which shows that because of on your
payments a lot of
services that have been authorized for
people to be taken care of at home can't
be
filled and really that's part of the
workforce crisis that
has caused the difficulties that we have
so i have submitted written testimony
and i just would speak to you today and
urge you to fully support
uh increases in the choices for
independence programs so that we can do
a better job of taking care of our
aging and adults with disabilities at
home thank you so much for your service
thank you for listening to me thank you
for your testimony
next up we have michelle merritt with
new futures
followed by emily johnson and scott
marion if you could both raise your
hands please
hi uh hopefully you can hear me and
maybe see me as well um
thank you thank you chairman weiler and
honorable members of the committee um
again my name is michelle merritt i'm
the president and ceo of new futures
um we appreciate the opportunity to
weigh in this afternoon for those who
are familiar with new features we're a
non-partisan non-profit
health policy and advocacy organization
doing work statewide to improve the
health and wellness of all granite
staters
in our role um we believe it's our
responsibility to educate
raise awareness and lead policy change
related to health and well-being
and in that vein this past summer new
futures surveyed hundreds of new
hampshire residents
across the state to try to gain a better
understanding of community needs during
this unprecedented time
and from this feedback we formed new
features five-point plan for a healthy
budget which we have provided copies of
with more detail to the committee we
believe that the five areas i'm just
going to quickly
run through um if fully funded in new
hampshire state budget would go far to
address
issues resulting from the covet 19
pandemic
as well as overcoming health disparities
for historically marginalized
marginalized groups and new hampshire's
children and families
so quickly those five points are
supporting local and public health
programs and services ensuring access to
health care by supporting a strong
healthcare workforce
supporting efforts to sustain and grow
behavioral health services in our
communities
sustaining investments that help
mitigate and prevent childhood trauma
to help grant state children and
families and protecting children's
behavioral health programs to ensure
coordinated and timely care for new
hampshire's youth
the governor's proposed budget did cover
numerous provisions in our five-point
plan but there are a few areas we want
to specifically call out
for attention by the committee so the
first
is something that christine daughter
just mentioned
from buy state primary care on the new
hampshire state loan repayment program
horrible acronym slurp but these funds
do represent a critical
investment to helping recruit and retain
workers
in new hampshire and we would encourage
the committee to preserve those funds
i also want to call out adolescent
tobacco and sud prevention
the dhhs tobacco prevention and
cessation unit did request an additional
000 in a prioritized need we would
encourage the committee to consider
funding that request early childhood
this is something that many people
before us have also spoke about
unfortunately 1.3 million dollars per
year from the department of health and
human service budget
for primary prevention programming was
cut we would like to see that restored
it's something the governor also
encouraged the committee to do um in his
march
4th letter and then finally new features
would really be remiss if we did not
clearly and unequivocally state our
support for the governor's
appropriations for children's behavioral
health
on march 14th new hampshire set a really
unfortunate record we had 51 kids
boarding in hospital emergency rooms
across the state
and i should have mentioned that the
children and families that are there
sorry thank you for the time i
appreciate it
thank you for your testimony next we
have emily johnson
followed by scott marion and roger
derosers
hello good afternoon my name is emily
johnson i am the state manager for save
the children action network in new
hampshire
at save the children action network we
believe all children deserve access to
high quality early childhood education
since 2014 we have worked in partnership
with community volunteers policy
advocates and state legislators to
improve accessibility and quality of new
hampshire's child care and early
learning programs
i'm here today to oppose cuts to
employment related child care funding in
house bill 1 which can be found
on page 950 of your budget book
employment related child care funds
grant assistance to hard-working
families with young children
parents who are income eligible for this
assistance benefit by having the ability
to continue to work and earn
a living while their children receive
high quality care and education
without this assistance new hampshire
children will miss out on high quality
foundational education
and their parents are likely to miss out
on earnings and or career advancement
while staying home with kids
employment related child care assistance
is essential not only for child
well-being but for working parents and
their ability to earn
money for basic costs of survival two
minutes
it is not unlikely for an income
eligible family to wind up qualifying
for increased state assistance
when denied child care scholarship due
to insufficient funds
when considering the essential nature of
these funds coupled with the impact kova
19 has had on working families i cannot
think of a worse time
to make the proposed cuts to this
funding while we cannot predict how many
working parents will be
income eligible for these scholarships
in the coming fiscal year
trends of pandemic related job loss and
unemployment
suggest that more families will require
child care assistance in coming years
i urge you to prioritize these families
and the efficiency of state dollars by
providing at least level funding
for employment related child care for
fiscal year 2022-2023
in conclusion i urge members of this
committee to amend house bill 1 to
include sufficient funding of
employment-related child care
it's a smart investment for the future
of our state uh while we focus on covet
19 recovery and beyond
thanks for your time today and for
letting me testify i'm happy to answer
any questions
uh thank you for your testimony we're
not set up to do any questions
next up we have scott marion
followed by roger derosers susan stearns
dunham
good afternoon um i'm scott marion
i live in ryan new hampshire i've been
on this vermont school board i've been
on the school board for eight years
and i uh i'll be short i uh nice to see
representatives
um i just want to uh
emphasize and i know that you guys
between the rock and roll
but i just want to emphasize uh the the
downshifting
that's in um governor's budget
and uh that will likely have to carry
through to
this bill unless you protect it but just
a very simple case now a little
uh budget relatively little compared to
earthquakes in the state
but not so little to us um there was a
significant increase
last year in our share of
downshifted those costs to the locals
and so
when you're trying to i need to balance
these budgets and i know you're driven
by revenue
and negotiations with the governor
but you have to recognize that the same
people are paying
whether you downshift into the towns and
oftentimes it makes it worse when you
downshift it to the towns
than when the state takes responsibility
so
education funding is a mess of the state
in general
and so i urge you to consider the total
cost
to taxpayers not just the state tab
thank you for your testimony next we
have
roger derosers followed by
susan stearns bonnie dunham and maureen
tracy
if you could all raise your hands thank
you
please
you are unmuted sir good afternoon
chairman wyler and members of the house
finance committee
my name is roger derosier i'm the chair
of the capital city task force for
aarp and i'm from concord
i'm a baby boomer in my 70s who is
looking down the road
at my possible future my possible future
need for
in-home services all of my friends and
fellow aarp members
share the same desire to remain in their
home when possible
it concerns me that the budget does not
include a raise
for all services in the state's choices
for independence program
cfi the services in this program
as i understand them allows individuals
to remain in their own home
versus a nursing home certainly i would
prefer to say in my own home that i have
known for years
and maintain my independence as long as
possible
this can happen only if a comprehensive
array of in-home services are available
to residents in need
two minutes the governor's proposed
budget does provide
some increases for some services to keep
people at home
but it doesn't go far enough the rate
increases for
some cfi services are not adequate
to attract and expand the needed
number of providers of these services
other services such as adult medical day
care
have not received an increase even when
this service is currently reimbursed
via medicaid at about half of the actual
cost
of 112 dollars per day as a result
many adult day care agencies have closed
in the last five to 10 years
cutting off services to medicaid and
private pay
individuals alike this is bad news for
new hampshire's
177 thousand unpaid family caregivers
many of whom could would and did use
this service
for needed respite without burden
burgeoning
the state budgets now
is the time to make budget increases for
an array of adult
in-home services as an alternative
to much more expensive nursing home care
as my generation ages the need for
in-home services
will increase geometrically by 2030
all baby boomers will be 65 or older
according to the u.s census baby boomers
in new hampshire will make up about a
quarter of its population
so it's imperative to make in-home
services available now
and prepare for the future growth thank
you for your consideration
next we have susan stearns followed by
bonnie dunham
good afternoon chairman wyler and
members of the committee
for the record my name is susan stearns
and i'm a resident of samberson
in the interest of full disclosure i am
employed as the deputy director of nami
new hampshire
and i volunteer as a board member at the
lakes region mental health center in
laconia
however today i come before you in
neither of those roles
instead i am here in my most important
role as a mother
i ask that you ensure that the budget
you pass
fully funds critically needed mental
health services
services that are accessible to all
granite staters
yesterday there were 55 adults and 22
children experiencing a mental health
crisis
waiting in emergency departments across
our state for an inpatient bed
we all know that this crisis has been
going on for over eight years
hundreds perhaps thousands of granite
staters of all ages have faced
this unacceptable delay in accessing
essential mental health care
two minutes this the story i have to
share with you
is one that is too common i fear is the
story of my
adult child who lives with a serious
mental illness
while traveling pre-covered days my
child phoned me
he was going through a recent medication
change and was in crisis
fearing he would hurt himself he felt he
might be suicidal
he asked if he should go to the local
emergency room
i did not know what to say
i have been his advocate since he was
first diagnosed with an emotional
disorder at the age of five
a serious one at age eight and a serious
mental illness at age fourteen
i have done this work as a mental health
advocate for over 20 years
this is what i do i advocate for people
with mental illness and their families
every day
i get calls from people who know me and
ask me for advice and
how to direct them for help for a loved
one
faced with my son in crisis over 500
miles away
i was terrified one minute i have
already sat at the bad side of a child
after a suicide attempt in that moment
when my second child
i was on the phone i was afraid for his
safety with him alone in the house
but i was also afraid for his safety
should he wind up boarding an emergency
department without an advocate at hand
he's sick sick not violent but highly
sensitive and emotional
he'd never had an inpatient psychiatric
admission
i feared that if he was stuck in an
emergency department for days
would he become upset would someone find
him threatening because of his size
in the hardest decision of my life i
told him no
do not go to the emergency department i
was able to access family support for
him and returned home the next day
we successfully managed his crisis with
his doctor
this is a story i rarely share sadly
though
i have heard it frequently from other
families other parents
those who know what it means for someone
experiencing a psychiatric crisis to
board for days or weeks in an emergency
department
thank you for taking the time to hear me
today i urge you to fully fund mental
health services
next we have bonnie dunham followed by
maureen
tracy and stephen gadu if you could raid
your hands
okay sorry it took me a minute to unmute
my name is bonnie dunham and i'm asking
you when you
pass the budget to please ensure that it
that it meets the needs of individuals
with developmental disabilities and
their families
by fully funding the developmental
services budget
i'm the mom of a wonderful socially
responsible 40 year old son who
experiences complex developmental
disabilities
john is fun he's determined he's
charming and he's a hard worker
he just celebrated his 20th anniversary
working at wendy's
sean is the only person i know who is
really happy to pay taxes because he
said that's part of being a good citizen
he's also an excellent civically minded
individual in the fact that he
volunteers he recycles he votes he picks
up litter
our town is better because sean lives
here sean is also
an enthusiastic consumer he makes sure
that he spends some of his paycheck
every week and
supporting our local schools and stores
and restaurants
so good that way too well sean is a
happy fully participating member of our
community
without the services he receives from
gateway's community services which is
our local area agency
his quality of life would be in jeopardy
john needs full-time one-on-one support
and supervision
my my husband and i provide that every
morning evening overnight and on the
weekends
gateways provide shawn with direct
supports on weekday hours and provide
some respite so that my husband and i
can sleep through the night every now
and then
and get an occasional break we adore our
son he makes our life joyful and it's
never dull in our house
but without the services we gateways
we could not continue to support sean in
our home and in his community activities
which is a tremendous cost savings to
the state
so as you consider the budget please
include full funding for the
developmental services budget
my son my family and many others like us
will thank you for it
and if i could add one more thing i i
had two more things one was the
department of corrections educational
programming so thank you for that
but the other one is that i hope you
prioritize
funding for public education including
special education
those additional funds will help towns
and school districts greatly thank you
very much thank you in advance i know
you'll do the right thing
and i thank you for all you've done so
far thank you bonnie
you're welcome next up we have stephen
gadu
followed by jeff dickinson and deborah
nelson if you could raise your hands
please
my name is stephen gardu i'm a member of
the budget committee here in salem new
hampshire and also a business owner here
in salem
i'm in support of hb1 i believe the
governor has
proposed a very responsible budget which
will keep the new hampshire advantage
very strong
a good budget is about the economy and
salem being a border town
our economy is dependent on the
a strong economy with no new taxes
and specifically no sales tax we have
business tax cuts we have roman meals
tax cuts
interest and dividend tax cuts all of
these things contribute
to a strong economy that we need in new
hampshire
we have uh it's proposed a paid
employment leave without imposing a tax
on participating
employees income that's also known as an
income tax that we're not going to have
in this budget
we have 30 million dollars going to
public school infrastructure fund
which downshifts cash to municipalities
instead of uh downshifting costs
to the uh municipalities i strongly
support this budget
um it i i've been listening to all this
testimony and i can understand
that there's an unlimited amount of
money that we could be possibly spending
on charitable programs
uh but that's not the charge of the
state the state's responsibility is to
facilitate a strong economy not a
welfare state
those who would prefer to live in a
welfare state don't need to go very far
thank you for your testimony next we
followed by deborah nelson and amanda
tol
hi there uh it's uh jeffrey dickinson
can you hear me
yes great uh well uh chairman weiler
and members of the committee thank you
for the opportunity to speak
with you today my name is jeff dickinson
and i live in franklin
and i'm here on behalf of myself but
also granite state independent living
which i serve as advocacy director for
and specifically i wanted to talk about
personal care
services i would echo what the folks
from
aarp have already said regarding fully
funding and
if possible increasing funding
for the choices for independence program
not only does it serve
those who are aging but it also serves
many of us
in the state with significant
disabilities
like myself to get assistance with
activities of daily living and things
that we're not physically able to do
ourselves
but that are required for us to you know
live our lives like everybody else would
i would also ask to
fully fund and increase funding if you
can for
what's known as personal care attendance
services
those are not under the cfi waiver those
are actually under the
medicaid state plan services and those
are
specifically for folks with significant
disabilities
who would otherwise be need to be in a
nursing home
and it basically provides services that
they may get a nursing home
in their own homes where
generally a lot of us would prefer to be
so that's really all i wanted to ask
and i thank you very much for your time
today
thank you for your testimony next we
have
deborah nelson followed by amanda toll
this is deborah nelson thank you very
much for
listening to me today i am a private
citizen i'm not speaking on behalf of
any particular organization i am now
retired
um but i have always had paid sick leave
in my jobs because i was a retired
i'm now a retired teacher and i was
fortunate in that respect
but i would like to speak about
the governor's paid family leave line
item in the budget
which i think simply maintains the
status
quo it upholds the system where
businesses who choose to provide leave
time
sick care will do so and those who
choose not to won't and i think
this will cause small businesses to
struggle against larger
employers and i've been listening for
the last
almost hour and 40 minutes to many
people speaking on a whole host of
issues
about the importance of whether it's
aarp
about providing the opportunity for
people to stay at home
or workers that provide services for
people with
mental illness with developmental issues
those workers those are the people who
need
this family leave plan who need
the supports that we can give them in
the budget
i feel strongly enough about this issue
despite my privilege and because of my
privilege to have had that benefit
that i have attended hearings in both
the house
and the senate about the family leave
bill
and so i urge you to
consider this to think about making new
hampshire a good place for workers
as the previous speaker spoke to the
importance of our economic strength we
are
only as strong as our workers
and our workers are only able to do
their job
if we treat them as human beings so i
thank you for this opportunity to speak
i hope you will address that line item
in the budget
i hope you will put money into places
that
enable us to be a strong and welcoming
economy
and state thank you very much for your
time
thank you for your testimony next we
have
representative amanda tolle
followed by karen blake and forrest
bowden
freed
hello can you hear me yes
okay prior to beginning my testimony i
just want to note when i originally
signed in to testify i registered my
support thinking that we were just
addressing
the one section of the bill relating to
crisis centers
please change my registered support to
neutral as i support
some sections of the budget but strongly
oppose others and want a people's budget
that is gracious towards funding social
services
i'm ready to begin my testimony my name
is amanda elizabeth toll
i'm here to bring to the committee's
attention the budget provision
that supports new hampshire crisis
centers
i am a representative serving cheshire
district
16. i'm also a survivor of domestic and
sexual violence
with first-hand knowledge of the
life-saving services provided by crisis
centers here in new hampshire
by the summer of 2017 i had experienced
two incidences of extreme violence in my
marriage
these experiences culminated in a
horrifying night where my husband jumped
on me and strangled me
after the strangulization i stopped
wanting to be intimate
with my son's father instead of
respecting my boundaries
he repeatedly sexually assaulted and
humiliated me for months
that summer i visited the monadnock
violence prevention center
to get help and advice they listened
with empathy
and talked to me about the ways i could
get out of the relationship safely
including filing a domestic violence
restraining order
acting on this advice i was able to
safely negotiate a divorce
the sexual violence i had been
experiencing for months post
strangulization stopped
and i became the primary parent of my
son
today i own a small business teach yoga
and am living a life free of violence
with my little boy
additionally i am a state representative
fighting for those who are still
suffering
none of this would have happened if i
had not been able to leave the abusive
relationship
i am so grateful to mcvp for their help
they are helping others to leave abusive
and violent situations
protect themselves and their families
and find freedom and empowerment
all while educating the public and
advocating for a future without
violence i am just one of thousands
across the state who has benefited from
the support of
advocates and crisis centers i was lucky
to have the financial support of my
family
many other victims become trapped in
abusive relationships because of their
lack of financial means
or suffering economic abuse crisis
centers are vital lifelines that link
survivors to resources
it is in the best interest of the state
to ensure that funding for these
valuable services is maintained
so that crisis centers are able to
respond to the needs of their
communities
let's support this crucial community
resource and ensure that other
individuals like me are able to safely
leave thank you representatives
in dangerous situations i respectfully
urge the committee to adopt the proposed
budget for our state's domestic violence
prevention program and ensure the crisis
centers are at a minimum level funded
thank you for your testimony thank you
next we have karen blake followed by
grewett
hello good afternoon and i'd like to
thank uh the
chairman and members of the finance
committee for allowing me to testify
today
my name is karen blake and i live in
north woodstock new hampshire
i am asking you to support the
developmental services budget and hb1
and the people who carry out the work
for full disclosure i work for northern
human services as the coordinator of
public policy and marketing
i apologize for the bing bong in the
back that's my husband's business
um we i um also
am a member of the new york uh northern
human services family support advisory
council
and i am on the board of new hampshire
for autism my husband and i are also
small business owners in the white
mountains
i am testifying today only on my own
behalf
my son is supported by northern human
services
through the in-home support waiver
and we but we've also had
family centered early supports and
services and we also had
family support today is my birthday
and it's a big one it's the kind of
birthday that makes you think about the
future
but the birthday that i want to talk
about is my sons
this past saturday my son turned 14
years old and in the developmental
disability community
that's a big one too um his this is the
age that under his individual education
plan we start to seriously start
planning for his for
for his future my son has big big plans
he aspires to be the next steven
spielberg and he want and he is going to
need the support to make his dreams a
reality
um as i previously stated he receives
in-home supports and we
finally found him a great match for his
in-home support provider
these services are helping him work on
key items like social interaction
um helping him to use money and he's
beginning to cook using a microwave
but we're looking beyond today and
someday he is likely going to need
support
to be a successful adult so i'm asking
you to fully fund developmental
disabilities
not just for my son but for everyone who
needs these services and supports to be
successful
thank you again for holding this this uh
public hearing virtually which is
allowing so many people to participate
from all over new hampshire safely today
thank you
thank you for your testimony next we
have
forrest bowden freed followed by
catherine grewett
hi uh this is um
forrest goodwin friday
um
yeah dear chairman everest and
members of the finest committee
on good afternoon
my name is forrest thunder friday
i am asking you today to fully
fund the developmental services
budget and to fund
the medicaid adult dental
benefit i receive
supports and services through the d-day
waiver and am also
a new hazard medicaid
recipient it is
extremely important for
granite staters with
disabilities that these priorities
are funded the supports
i receive through the dd
waiver helped me to live independently
in my own apartment
work part-time volunteer and my
community
and stay involved and activism
for these reasons fully
funding for developmental
services is essential
for maintaining my
community based life
as medicaid recipient
funding for an adult
gentle benefit as important
because i care about living a
healthy lifestyle and oral
health is an important part of overall
health
getting in any wall dental cleaning
is much less expensive in fixing
calories or treating chronic conditions
caused by
poor poor health thank you
next we have catherine grewett
followed by asthma el huni and rebecca
skye
can you hear me yes oh okay
um first i wanted to thank joseph
lacoste for
for his testimony and i'm
also discussing the new hampshire
department of corrections education
facility and the housing units the
transitional housing
my name is catherine gruett i'm a
resident of senator barnstead new
hampshire
i am writing to you to consider fully
cons
funding all the educational programs at
the department of corrections
the inmates choose to help themselves in
their recovery from the trauma and shame
they feel from the physical disease of
addiction
the education classes help their mental
health as well as teaching them a skill
that they can use
when they reintegrate into society the
classes give them
a goal and help them to make a plan to
make their recovery successful
they get away from the trauma of being
in the general population where there is
noise and anxiety surrounding you
constantly
to a quiet disciplined classroom with
dedicated teachers
the teachers not only teach them classes
and skills but teach them how to build
up their self-esteem
and how to fit into society in the
future
they learn the skills to be employed
which leads to paying taxes
child support and paying off their debts
it is a win for the teachers who are
devoted to making life better for the
inmates and the community they will
move into it is a win for the inmate who
will be contributing to society
and the family and it is a win for the
community that surrounds them
it costs money to fully fund this but it
takes money education and treatment to
cure this epidemic of addiction that is
filling our prisons
please support our state by financing
this department of correction education
fully partial support is a failure
and i hope that you'll support all the
teachers and keep the entire staff
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony and we have good news on
that education corrections
next we have asma el huni
i hope he's there i've not seen a hand
hello can you hear me yes thank you my
name is ismael huni and i'm the movement
politics director for rights and
democracy new hampshire
and as a renewed coalition member we
promote the following as a human rights
budget
this is something many organizations
have come together to share as a
people's budget
some of the coalition members are poor
people's campaign granite state progress
rights and democracy
american friends service committee and
many other orgs here goes
new hampshire's people deserve a state
budget that invests in our communities
health education recovery
opportunity and vitality in order to
achieve this
we also need fair and adequate taxation
that invites all of us to contribute
to the common good in according with our
ability to pay
with this in mind we call for the
following as elements of the people's
budget of new hampshire
one invest in our recovery from covid19
with full funding for public health
economic stability for renters
homeowners and small businesses
increased access to broadband internet
equipment for remote learning and remote
access to public meetings two
invest in real economic security by
addressing the needs of low-income
families for financial assistance for
food
heat rent and transportation including
undocumented and mixed status families
as eligible for these investments
three invest in our state workers with a
livable wage
good benefits and fulfillment of our
obligations for their dignified
retirement
four investing adequately in public
health
public schools and quality public
education so that all new hampshire
children have an opportunity to learn
to achieve their to their full potential
five
invest in our young adults who deserve
affordable high higher education
student loan debt relief and access to
affordable rental housing
six invest in people with disabilities
and their families
by fully funding all disability services
and supports
seven invest in our children and their
parents with affordable high quality
child care
eight invest in our elders with supports
for aging in place and relief
from burdensome property taxes nine
invest in health
so that all new hampshire people have
access to high high quality affordable
health care including affordable
medications as well as paid family
medical leave and paid sick leave
invest in harm reduction and overdose
prevention that moves us away from
punitive measures to community solutions
that center people's health and
well-being this means addressing
substance use disorder
as a health condition not a crime using
evidence-based public health strategies
we cannot effectively deal
with sud without addressing the
underlying issues in our communities
that make it difficult for people to
cope
with life's overwhelming struggles and
also
invest in bipac black indigenous people
of color communities recognizing that
they are the most impacted by injustice
and that as a state we must write our
wrongs and discontinue
practices that disadvantaged by poc
truth and reconciliation for black
indigenous and immigrant communities is
a necessary first step
um uh the next thing is invest in
survivors by supporting social services
that support crisis senators
survivors and last thing i'll say is i
personally don't support
any increase in the criminal justice and
your three minutes are up
but i just want to say i do find it
interesting that there are cuts that are
being made
um in the criminal justice system in the
areas of housing units where
that actually benefits people who are
incarcerated thank you for your
testimony
and last we have on the list rebecca
skye
and he's being promoted and mr carr i'm
going to turn the
arm over to mr hoffman after this
testimony
uh good afternoon chairman weiler and
members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony my
name is rebecca skye and i serve as the
executive director for the new hampshire
commission on aging
the commission was established during
the 2019 legislative session to advise
the governor and the general court
on policy and planning related to aging
forward thinking public policy
will ensure that all of us have the
opportunity to thrive contribute
and be valued in new hampshire as we age
first i want to
voice my support for doug mcnutt and
jeffrey dickinson's comments in relation
to the choices for independence waiver
we need to encourage provision of
services at home and in community rather
than in long-term care facilities there
are many good considerations in the
budget proposed by the governor
i will take the moment to highlight just
one missed opportunity that is
critically important
the bureau of elderly adult services
options system modernization
the current baas option system was
developed in 1998 and initially
installed in 1999
which makes it a 23 year old system it
is truly anachronistic
and not suited to achieve the efficiency
you need to realize in state government
it is used to manage beas social work
caseloads the adult protection program
and service authorization and provider
payments related to the social services
block grant and the older americans
act services the current system is not
web-based and does not allow for remote
access
offline access or any of the needed
enhanced system functionality required
for the variety of locations and user
types that the beas
business model currently utilizes beas
social workers
service link personnel and contract
agencies now do significant field work
realizing efficiencies that benefit both
the residents of our state
and the state budget bottom line covet
has only highlighted the increased value
of staff nimbleness to conduct remote
meetings and to enter
and access data remotely if this
modernization project which was
submitted as part of the capital request
is not funded then the department
will need to hire an additional 4.5
full-time employees to maintain current
work capacity
in summary the the options system is 23
year old is a 23 year old system that
needs to be updated to help eas better
manage va's social work
or caseload without the upgrade improved
business processes are not supported
customer services
could decline an additional personnel
will be needed for data entry and
manipulation
if funded new hampshire will not have to
bear the price tag of the modernization
project alone
the federal financial participation is
anticipated at 40 percent of the total
cost
so thank you for your consideration on
that and with my remaining time i just
want to respond to two elements of hb2
thank you for recognizing the extremely
negative impact of socialization on
isolation on older adults with the
appropriation of the 1.5 million for
senior centers and other senior serving
organizations
uh though on on the other hand i however
i have concerns for the repeal the
senior volunteer program
which also addresses social isolation um
we've all learned through this pandemic
the
the high toll of social isolation thank
you so much for your consideration
thank you thank you for your testimony
and going back over the list
are any of the people that didn't answer
earlier show up later
i can read the list of names um before
mr hoffman takes over
i just sent a note to them um elizabeth
o'neill
julian doucette nancy kelleher
carolyn virtue cheryl bailey
aaron bouvier elliott berry
maureen tracy if any of you folks are
available please raise your hand
and anyone else that is not any of those
people could you please lower your hand
so we can all the folks that have signed
up first before
mr chair uh the next person to speak is
maria i don't have a last name for her
allowing people with their hands up
their virtual hand up to speak and
that's either done by
raising your hand in zoom or
pressing star nine on your telephone
thank you for the opportunity i don't
know why it's not showing my full name
my name is state representative maria
perez i'm a staff representative for the
623 in milford
um today i'm testifying because i
believe
during this pandemic we need to
provide more benefits and more more
programs for people in our community
especially the mental health
illness is some of the programs that we
need
to get more money and then we need to
get more programs to our communities to
be honest
i see the struggles in my own community
i see
younger generations losing their life
because they're not getting the proper
mental health illness uh programs needed
in our communities the other thing that
i'm
i'm like seeing and i i witnessed it
myself
and i i was part of
part of the people who uh witness what
happened in manchester with a a
homeless community thank you
uh we have so many people that they're
going they're struggling with a homeless
situation right now
and uh this budget up is not going to
help our community is going to make it
harder for our communities especially
the ones who have been loose on the jobs
because of the pandemic we have to
provide them with with a
help necessary to make sure that we
don't have any more people
getting into the homeless situation and
then the other thing that is uh
i'm a survivor of domestic and sexual
assault
and i believe during this pandemic we
see more cases of people
especially people in our minority groups
they're not getting the proper help we
need to make sure that
in this budget we get enough money to
provide help
for these uh these programs our
community that struggles
so hard right now and lastly uh we need
to provide
help with up property taxes people
they can't they has to uh choose between
paying for the property taxes
or putting food on the table so some of
the programs that i i will encourage you
to help us
please uh help the people who own um
houses and they struggle and to pay
their property taxes make sure we don't
have
more homeless people in our state thank
thank you for your testimony i missed
your name could you say it slowly
yes um my name is uh state
representative maria perez
and i'm a state representative from
district district 23
milford new hampshire thank you
next we'll hear from amanda sears
bourdoin
hello thank you thank you chairman
weiler and members of the committee
i am the director of the campaign for a
family friendly economy we are working
to help working
families make ends meet and be there for
their families to meet their caregiving
obligations
i want to address two items in the
budget first
hb1 inadequately funds and in fact makes
significant cuts
to the child care scholarship program
that helps working families to afford
child
care second we are opposed to section
69 to 74 of hb2
related to paid family leave the
pandemic has highlighted the financial
insecurity that
unexpected health threats and related
time away from work
can cause for working families right now
more than two-thirds of working people
in new hampshire lack access to paid
family and medical leave
and there is significant disparity
between who has and who lacks paid leave
women and people with caregiving
responsibilities including families with
a person experiencing disability
are far less likely to have paid family
and medical leave
and these same working people are more
likely to have a need for time away from
work to meet caregiving needs
low-income workers and families making
less than sixty thousand per year
are also less likely to have paid family
and medical leave
nothing in the sections of hb2 dealing
with paid leave would relieve these
disparities
the proposal that is in hb2 is also
unfunded
there are no estimates of what the cost
of the program will be to the general
fund
today before division one the governor's
office indicated there are no new funds
included in hb1
to cover the costs of state employee
premiums which could be in the ballpark
of 2.6 million dollars per year
or staffing for the department of admin
services or employment security
when the language in these sections were
in a standalone bill senate bill 730
last year the fiscal note indicated that
the costs associated with that language
would be three million dollars to build
the individual pool
premium collection system and 1.7
million annually for administration
but those are not included in hb1 are
detailed in hb2
private businesses that choose to
contract with a private insurance
company would get a significant public
benefit in the form of tax credits
if uh this is not also not indicated in
the bill
if 50 of our employees were covered by
businesses that chose that tax credit
the cost to the bet could equal 29.29
million dollars per year
and that revenue loss is not indicated
in the budget not including any of these
costs or revenue implications for the
program
make it hard to believe there is any
real commitment to seeing the sections
of this bill realized
there are also far too many policy
implications that should have been dealt
with in a policy committee
including that this lacks any real
protection for retaliation or job loss
for individuals in the pool that would
be administered by the state
or for employers with under 20 employees
there's no process for appeals of denied
claims
thank you and your time is up thank you
very much for your testimony you're
welcome
next we'll hear from lisa bedoyne
followed by
hi there good afternoon chairman and
members of the house finance committee
for the record my name is lisa beaudoin
i serve as executive director of able
new hampshire the granite state's
disability justice
organization free from public funds able
new hampshire
its board and members urge you to fully
support the budget for the developmental
disability community
and go beyond it we're asking you to
include full funding for a medicaid
adult dental
benefit which is listed as a priority
need
from the state office of medicaid but
not included in the governor's budget
we would also like you to support the
in-home supports waiver
the choices for independence waiver and
the acquired brain disorder waiver
thereby covering all members of the
disability community
it's time to reverse pennywise and pound
foolish
health care policies which significantly
contribute to people with disabilities
experiencing the poorest health outcomes
of any identified population
in america as you have previously heard
from abel
in other years and other sessions the
data is clear that people with poor oral
health struggle to secure employment
among the many consequences of poor oral
health
people with disabilities already face
discrimination from potential
employers who believe the myth that
people with disabilities are not quite
worthwhile employees
and as a population people with
disabilities experience the highest
rates of poverty of
any identified group in part due to
these kinds of myths
so which kind of employer is going to
hire a person with a disability whose
mouth is full of decay
and in periods of pain if new hampshire
is interested in raising the rates of
employment as well
as improving health outcomes and
lowering health care costs
for people with disabilities and other
vulnerable citizens on medicaid
we must finally make providing fiscally
sound and comprehensive oral health care
in new hampshire
the law and we have to pay for it
and in closing rsa rsa 171a
mandates that the new hampshire
legislature fully fund the adult
developmental disability service system
people with disabilities must have the
support that they are entitled to to
participate in the american dream
to share their strengths and talents to
work and to be robustly engaged in their
communities
again please fully fund all the medicaid
waivers
and fund the medicaid adult dental
benefit if you have any questions
you can contact me thank you thank you
mr chair we have diane bolduc who wishes
to speak
good afternoon um thank you chairman and
members
of the committee thank you for your
service to our state
it's not an easy task to come up with a
reasonable budget that meets everyone's
needs i will be as brief as possible i
wish
to ask you to fully support funding for
develop
the programs for developmentally
disabled persons in our state
um not only because it's the right thing
to do
but particularly with the early supports
and services program our birth to three
program it is the financially wise thing
to do
it has been demonstrated and that and
documented that for every dollar spent
between the
ages of birth and three on developmental
programs seven dollars is saved over the
lifetime of that child by school
districts by the criminal justice system
by employers insurance companies and by
all of us as citizens
so i again i ask you to please fully
support
all services for our developmentally
disabled population and particularly
to fully fully fund the early supports
and family centered early sports and
services program
thank you for your time thank you for
your testimony
glad to do it mr chair next to speak
is amy moore and uh
ms moore is the last person with their
hi yes i'm here can you hear me
yes thank you good afternoon mr chairman
members of the committee my name is amy
moore i'm the director of ascentria
in-home
care which provides personal care
services for over 400 people
through cfi the choices for independence
program which you've heard
doug mcnutt and jeff dickinson speak on
earlier
i just want to follow up on some of
their remarks um i also serve on the
board of the home care hospice and
palliative care alliance of new
hampshire
thousands of granite staters depend on
the cfi program these are low-income
medically vulnerable individuals
anywhere from 18 years old to
104 who qualify for nursing homes but
choose to remain in their own home as we
know
people overwhelmingly choose and wish to
remain in their own homes
home and community-based care costs a
fraction of what a nursing home does
unfortunately these programs have been
under underfunded for over a decade
so badly so that new hampshire ranks
50th in the amount of medicaid funding
it spends on home and community-based
care
two minutes currently cfi is failing our
most vulnerable citizens
rates are so low that providers cannot
hire workers they need to to care for
these individuals
agencies that provide cfi care lose
money or struggle to break even
the rates don't cover the full cost of
training supervision billing background
checks tv tests
you get it individuals can go to work at
market basket mcdonald's walmart and
receive a higher
wage um my 13 year old daughter can
babysit next door
and um receive a higher wage we hail
these caregivers these health care
workers as heroes during the pandemic
yet we won't pay them a livable wage
while i appreciate the work that has
been done
that has been done to fix these rates
when something has been neglected for
over a decade it takes more than these
these small incremental changes based on
dhhs zone data
the entire cfi approach appropriation is
rarely spent
this isn't because it's too large it's
because agencies can't provide the
services
funds are being left on the table that
could enhance rates and eliminate these
gaps in care
without immediate meaningful changes to
the cfi
program many providers will be forced to
shutter their programs
leaving new hampshire's most vulnerable
citizens without care the health care
consequences for new hampshire's
vulnerable citizens receive
receiving sporadic or no cfi care at all
can be deadly we've seen this
just as with people with developmental
disabilities or mental illness granite
staters who need
long-term care should be able to remain
in their homes and community and not be
subjected to unwanted and unnecessary
institutionalization
new hampshire is already the second
oldest state in the country and our
population continues to age
we must strengthen our home and
community-based care system now
thank you for the opportunity to speak
representative weiler i see no more
hands raised
if if people are in attendance and would
like to
testify you can raise your hand and zoom
or by hitting star 9 on your telephone
and we have audrey gerkin who would like
to speak
yes audrey go ahead hi thank you
my name is audrey gerkin i live in
brentwood new hampshire
i'm asking you to support the
developmental
services budget in hb1
my daughter lexi is 19 years old and
supported by
one sky community services through
family support for her
transition to adult services lexi
is a mischievous teenager who loves time
with family and friends
she attends school at the monarch school
of new england
where her staff and friends enjoy her
jokes and pranks
that can be that can include carefully
placed
rubber chickens she enjoys life this way
even though she is non-verbal and in a
wheelchair
because of the services she receives
she is diagnosed with cornelia de lange
syndrome
which comes with many complex medical
needs
her medical her medicaid secondary
coverage includes
two full-time nurses and one part-time
nurse
this allows my husband and i to work and
raise lexi's two
younger sisters at this time lexi is
actively working towards trans
transitioning
to adult services we are in the thick of
applying for
ssi and adult medicaid services
i can attest for the need of upgraded
computer technology
and the increase of dhhs personnel
within the developmental services budget
as we push through this complicated
process
these upgrades would allow for a better
more streamlined
efficient process and afford less stress
on families thank you and please
fully fund the developmental services
budget
thank you thank you for your testimony
mr chair a jennifer bertrand would like
okay
good afternoon um uh chairman edwards
and members of the house finance
committee my name is jennifer bertrand
and i live with my family in mont vernon
new hampshire
i too am asking you to fully fund the
developmental services portion of the
budget that support our home and
community-based waivers to provide
people with developmental and other
disabilities with long-term care and
supports
i'm proud mom of four children and my
daughter chloe is now
21 years old she transitioned in august
during the pandemic this past year
from her school services into adult
developmental services
and because the legislature last year or
in the last biennium
fully funded the weightless portion of
the budget as well as the developmental
other sections of the developmental
services budget
she was able to transition seamlessly
and
we've helped to support her we provide
wrap around care
we've we've helped her to start a small
business chloe shred shed
she has a passion for shredding um but
because
those services were fully funded chloe
has
the services she needs so she can live a
meaningful life she can support herself
um you know help support herself
financially
and because when she was a child because
she was
a recipient of the in-home supports
waiver she was able to grow
up at home with her family attend her
local public schools
so please fully fund the developmental
services portion of the budget
it's helping people live great lives and
be as productive as they can be
thanks for your time and appreciate your
efforts and leadership thank you for
mr chair i currently see no hands um if
anyone would like to speak
please do so by raising your hand in
zoom
i do not see any more hands at this time
okay we still see people on a list but i
guess maybe they came to listen
and if nobody else puts their hand up in
the next two minutes i will close this
mr chair we have elizabeth grino who
would like to speak
all right bring her on elizabeth
elizabeth if you unmute
okay um can you hear me now yes
i just wanted to ask uh for the
developmental
disabilities budget to be put through as
well thank you very much for
all of your efforts and endeavors for
people living with developmental
disabilities in the state of new
hampshire
i am new to the state and i have a
six-year-old son
who is a person living with williams
syndrome and
we appreciate all of your time and
efforts uh for
people living with disabilities who will
need
this financial help in the future thank
you
thank you and welcome to new hampshire
thank you
mr chair we have a telephone caller
with the number ending 726
we'll uh we'll pull them over and ask
them to identify themselves say that
uh we we have a phone caller um
we're gonna ask them to okay all we have
is the phone number
we're gonna ask them to uh introduce
themselves
and if you press star six on your phone
hi my name is karen trudell can you hear
me
yes say your name again karen trudell
t-r-u-d-e-l for the record
i am a consumer on mental health i have
worked with
nami new hampshire but i am a member of
the general
public i am completely worried
i have seen what um governor sununu has
proposed as far as mental health
for the budget um i'm just concerned
because of covid we had you know we were
so prepared with a covid surge
um that we turned nh to uh nhti's
um gym for a like a covid surge
area and what i'm wondering is if
there's any way we can do that for
mental health
especially because there are 55 adults
this is
susan stearns mentioned as well as 22
children
waiting in er for a bed i don't know if
you have a family member
who has ever been at a hospital
sitting in vr waiting for a bed and it
is not fun i can tell you from
experience you're along with your
thoughts and
thoughts aren't pretty if you're already
at the hospital
my other thought was since covid
is i mean it's getting a little better
here in the state but i was wondering if
there was any way that we could
try to identify a way to maybe put
mental health
i don't know what they're doing with the
gym at nhgi
phase out some of the people that are
stuck in the er right now
um and maybe opening up the gym for them
so that they have a place to talk about
how they're feeling
and maybe get that turnaround going um
and then the other thing i've always
said too
we've been talking about this for so
long the 10-year plan i would
love to see that fully funded but more
importantly
medicaid reimbursement i can tell you in
i had three of my mental health care
providers
retire and i know that that
happened but it was all in the same year
and it's very unnerving to have to start
over
with new doctors since then i've had to
start with four new psychiatrists
and it is never easy and you think
you've got
one and then oh look i'm leaving i'm
going here
oh look well i had to move out of state
my family
had to go somewhere else and the latest
one
accused me of not taking my meds and i
was like i'm sorry
you don't know me from a hole in the
wall um so i just would really hope that
you guys can
consider funding as much as you can the
mental health services i did see that
governor sununu was taking it very
serious and i know that he has been
for quite some time since he's been in
office so
i appreciate anything you can do and
nami
is nami new hampshire does as well thank
you for your time
thank you for your testimony we have put
more money into mental health but
there's a shortage of practitioners
and spaces in the in hospitals and so on
and we're working on those
but that's a long-term fix sorry about
your problems thank you for your
testimony
mr chair we have maria with her hand up
would like to speak
okay
um mr shirt thank you again for the
opportunity i know that i already spoke
but i
i just want to bring into your attention
that i um
one of the things that are people um
saying and then i witnessed myself
um last weekend i was in the emergency
room
and i went witness people with mental
illness
needing help and then the hospital
didn't have a place for people to to get
the
that um needed a treatment from menthol
so i will i will ask all of you to
think about ways that we can uh provide
more i know that probably we don't have
enough people we don't have that uh
the room necessary in our hospital but
we have to figure it out
because we're losing a lot of lives in
our communities especially during the
pandemic
we see more people struggling in mental
health illness
it's huge we don't we don't think that
it is a big deal but it is
and and and i believe that we have we
have the potential to save more lives
but we have to be open to
listen to to the struggle that hospitals
and people in our community are going
through right now
and again my name is maria perez
and i stay representative for district
23.
thank you again representative alvarez
because of the pandemic we've had a huge
increase in mental illness
we've also added a lot of money in this
last fiscal year
but nevertheless we can't keep up we
don't have the
uh we don't have the practitioners and
we don't have the space but we're
working on it it's a long-term fix thank
you
no thank you
chair i see no hands currently
all right give me a time for two minutes
and then we'll call it
mr chairman time has expired
seeing no further uh participants
i'm closing this public hearing for the
finance committee
i thank all the members who showed their
patience for sticking with us all this
time
i especially thank the legislative
budget assistance staff
and the i.t staff for setting all these
things up
and i thank you all for being here and
for your patience i thank the public
for letting us know what they think is
important and most that we're dealing
with already